right now coming up on 508 on your
monday morning so starting today we've
talked about this
construction starts on 10 miles of
nellis
trop on the south all the way up to
craig road more than 30
000 cars there every day our bianca
holman is live breaking down the changes
you're going to have to wiggle your way
through hey bianca
hey good morning nae yes changes are
coming to the east side of the valley
the
nevada department of transportation is
starting construction
today at nellis and tropicana and then
like you said wrapping up at craig robe
now here's a little bit more information
about this project
it's a 26 million project it will create
a safer and more pedestrian friendly
corridor
asphalt and street lights they'll be
replaced and there's also be new
signage at major intersections of sahara
charleston boulevard and bonanza road
new handicap accessible ramps
sidewalks and driveways will be
installed now all this work will happen
sunday night through friday evening
and of course during this construction
there will be lane restrictions so indot
encourages drivers
to use caution when traveling through
this work zone
of course pay attention to those
construction signs or take an alternate
route if possible
now this project is due to wrap up in
mid-2022
but also some good news it is providing
more than 300 jobs here in this area
reporting from nellis and tropicana
avenue bianca holman
8 news now